[Music]
welcome to this special episode of tech
news briefing for Monday April 10th I'm
Zoe Thomas for The Wall Street Journal
this is the second episode of our series
artificially minded where we look at how
artificial intelligence is changing our
lives livelihood and culture the first
episode AI 101 aired last week if you
haven't heard that yet go check it out
it's a great primer on how AI works and
why this moment is different but there
are so many questions about the way new
generative AI Technologies could affect
us so today we're taking a little time
to answer your questions
thank you to everyone who sent something
in with me to answer them is wsj Tech
reporter Karen Howe hi Karen thanks for
being here thanks so much for having me
Zoe so we got quite a lot of great
questions but before we dive into them
you've been covering AI developments for
a while I want to know what you're
watching closely
I'm really excited that so many people
are finally starting to really pay
attention to AI development and starting
to participate and kind of ask questions
around where this technology comes from
who's developing it because this
technology is so influential that it
really does require the participation of
so many people so I'm that's really what
I'm watching I'm watching how people are
coming online scrutinizing this thing
and making a development more a part of
the thing that they care about
all right let's get into some of the
listener questions here's the first one
hello my name is Rob Franco from San
Antonio Texas
my question is to what extent is
generative AI producing you know sort of
crazy results you ask the question
and you get an answer that doesn't make
any sense or you get an answer to a
question that doesn't make any sense
so I think here what Ralph is talking
about are AI hallucinations can you tell
us what those are and why they occur
so the thing about how generative AI
works I think there's a common
misconception that when you're chatting
with child gbt it's sort of scanning the
internet for information and then
synthesizing it for you that's not
exactly how it works it's actually
trying to construct sentences that sound
reasonable based on the probability of
certain words and phrases being
frequently used together so it's not
actually identifying specific pieces of
information it's literally just kind of
a really powerful autocomplete where it
takes words and then assembles them
based on the frequency in which it sees
it within the internet text it's
difficult to quantify how often that
produces something like a hallucination
but a really good rule of thumb is to
think about when you're asking about
something what do you think would be the
quality of the data that chap gbt or the
AI tool was trained on if you're asking
about something that is like really
common knowledge then it's very likely
you'll get correct information because
it has just said so often on the
internet but if you start asking about
something really Niche or really Fringe
or areas that are actually known to have
really high levels of misinformation on
the internet that's when you are going
to start getting garbage reflected in
these answers and this is also really
relevant depending on the language that
you ask these tools your questions in if
you're speaking in English and a lot of
the English language data on the
Internet is more high quality then
you'll get more high quality answers but
if you're speaking in a different
language especially minority languages
that are not as commonly used on the
internet then the quality of the answers
will rapidly decline
okay this question comes from Ayala
Stone who is a high school math teacher
in Maryland my question is is it
possible to know for sure that a student
is plagiarizing chat CPT
that's such a good question not really
I mean hopefully at this moment in time
if you've known a student for long
enough as a teacher you would start to
recognize if there are things that are
off about you know they might be
performing at a different level than
they usually do or they're using
language they usually don't but to be
honest as Chachi BT becomes more and
more common and you start having
students in your class that start in
your class with using chat gbt it'll be
really hard for teachers to figure out
where that information is coming from I
mean this is certainly a question that
we've heard from a lot of teachers
professors even parents are there any
tools out there at the moment to help
people figure out when chat GPT is being
copied or used for homework assignments
there are definitely tools where you can
do a quick check to see if text has been
generated by AI the issue is that the
tools aren't accurate and they're really
easy to game because they're looking for
the exact output of Chachi BT or
whatever other AI generated tool and
it's quite easy for a student to just
edit things a little bit to suddenly
fool the detection system
okay this
is a big one and I think a lot of people
will be curious about this
I
live in Salisbury North Carolina what
I'm wondering is are researchers
actively trying to prevent a singularity
where AI becomes as intelligent or more
intelligent than human being
yeah that's a really great question that
is definitely on a lot of people's minds
I think there's sort of two questions
actually that are being asked here one
is are researchers trying to prevent AI
from becoming more intelligent than
human beings and then the other one is
are they then trying to prevent The
Singularity which is the moment in which
technology becomes so powerful that it
becomes uncontrollable by humans the
first part of that question is that open
AI is actively trying to create AI that
is smarter than human beings that is
their stated Mission they said that
their mission is to create artificial
general intelligence or AGI which is
broadly defined as AI that can outdo
humans in a wide variety of tasks but
there are a lot of efforts within the AI
research Community to try to do this in
a safe way I think there's a wide range
though of how people Define what safe
means so open AI is working on things
like alignment which is about out trying
to create these systems that are smarter
than humans but we'll also follow our
values and continue to work together
with us collaboratively but there's
movements like the slow AI movement
that's about building this technology
slower so that we can be more thoughtful
at every step of the process for how to
build in guard rails whether that's
policy guard rails or technical guard
rails there's also approaches like
participatory AI which is about
involving more of the community in
building AI so that the community
themselves can actually say what they
want out of these Technologies and
design for Technology Solutions that are
relevant to the problems that they face
Karen we've seen a lot of different uses
for AI so far but now we've got a
question on what role it might play next
it's Rodney Moda from
and I'm actually wondering about AI
Beyond it for functional or helpful
purposes but more for
emotional or friendship purposes what
are your thoughts on how people will use
it to create friendship becomes friends
with it how long will that take or will
it be normalized I love that question
from Freddy it is a really really good
one
um there have been some really great
articles looking at communities of
people who use this app called replica
to create AI boyfriends or girlfriends
that's probably like one of the most
common manifestations of people turning
to AI for relationships there's
definitely upsides and downsides the
upside that I was really surprised in
reading some of this reporting is that
you might assume that people turning to
AI would become more introverted and
less social but in many instances in
having a supportive Dynamic with an AI
it brings people out of their shell it
actually makes them go in more hikes it
makes them explore their neighborhoods
more but then the downside is that you
basically are Outsourcing a really
important relationship to a company so I
think we will start seeing this more and
more it will become more normal over
time but I would just encourage people
who are thinking about incorporating
this into their own lives that they
should be aware that they are giving up
a lot of their data to a private company
and they are sort of at the whims of the
company for the nature of their
relationship
all right let's move on to a few
questions about law and regulation
this first one comes from Zoe so who's
so from Chicago Illinois
I wanted to ask what you think the legal
space surrounding generative AI is going
to look like for example we'll
algorithms be subjected to the same
copyright laws as humans when the
algorithm is being trained on licensed
content or will we need new copyright
laws specifically for Content that
algorithms train on
this is such a Hot Topic and it's really
unknown right now there's actually cases
moving through court right now with
artists suing AI tool companies for
using their copyrighted images to
develop these tools and there's also one
with coders that are suing companies as
well for developing code generation
systems on their code and the argument
that the artists are making is that
these images are copyrighted and the
companies should not be allowed to just
Hoover up all of our copyrighted images
and start generating things in the style
of our art or derivative of the style of
our art and companies are arguing that
this is like technology development and
AI needs this kind of data it should be
fair use otherwise if you just get rid
of the ability of these tools to learn
from all kind of copyright information
it would really hamper the development
of these tools
so this is a really big debate and
artists are definitely really heavily
trying to push for algorithms
essentially to be held to the same
standard as humans because if they are
not it could be devastating they argue
to their livelihoods and Karen some
listeners also wanted to know about the
global regulatory landscape here is
artem bedkovsky from Westfield New
Jersey if AI is regulated in United
States or Europe and not regulated in
China
would it give an upper hand in the eye
competition to the authoritarian regimes
so what's really interesting is China is
actually more heavily regulated than the
US when it comes to AI development the
US has no federal law around AI China
has a few laws around this one of the
most recent ones is actually a law on
quote-unquote deep synthesis
Technologies which is essentially
China's term for generative Ai and it
stipulates that any kind of tool that is
a generative AI tool needs to make sure
that it doesn't spew misinformation that
it's labeled if it could fool users into
thinking that it's actually real output
there are definitely some issues around
the way that that China has written the
law but in general the premise that I
think is sort of popularized in the west
or in the U.S especially by members of
Congress is that China has no regulation
around these things so the U.S really
shouldn't Implement regulation to fall
behind but actually China has been quite
fast and quite aggressive in regulating
some some of these areas and I'm curious
Karen these regulations in China they're
fairly new but do we have a sense of how
well they're working because this is a
difficult thing to try and come in and
regulate there are a lot of questions
and there's a lot of skepticism around
whether or not some of the regulations
that China has written will actually be
implementable or enforceable and that is
we don't really know right now how it's
going to play out because they are so
new they basically came into effect in
just the last few months but in terms of
looking at a model for AI regulation
that seems really promising thus far I
think Europe is actually really stand
out in the way that it is advancing
these issues and thinking about how to
write regulation that is more
enforceable so the EU right now has the
Digital Services Act and the digital
markets act and it's also in the process
of drafting the AI act that are all sort
of interlocking laws that are trying to
to handle issues around data privacy
around platform use of AI around the
amplification of misinformation on
platforms and around generative AI tools
all right Karen our last question is a
little technical
my name is Danny Leal and I'm from
Jacksonville Florida
and my question is since
new technology the AI technology
how is the possibility for that
technology to be integrated to
um Quantum Computing is that a
possibility
okay Karen before you get into that
answer can you just start by reminding
us what quantum computers are
so the way to think about a quantum
computer is your laptop is what
scientists would call a classical
computer so all of the information that
is encoded in your laptop is encoded
with bits which are these like digital
ones and zeros that are then
representing things like numbers that
then can help represent images can
represent text or anything that ends up
showing up on your computer screen but
quantum computers they represent
information in a totally different way
using what are known as Quantum bits and
essentially Quantum bits are trying to
exploit the really weird physics that
happens at microscopic levels um like at
the particle level where a particle can
be a zero and a one at the same time
so the principle of a quantum computer
is that if you can somehow successfully
control these Quantum bits and get them
to organize themselves in a way that
allows you to get them to compute
information then the computation would
happen like super fast
the issue with quantum computers right
now is that
scientists haven't really figured out
how to control Quantum bits which means
that they're not so useful when you're
trying to compute anything but the
reason why quantum computers would
become so powerful for artificial
intelligence is because AI at its core
is just a ton of math problems like the
computer is crunching lots and lots of
numbers doing lots of math to try to
find patterns in data and if you could
just have a far more powerful
computational device that crunches
numbers and does the math way faster
than you could do problems that might
take a classical computer thousands of
years in a Split Second
okay we'll have to leave it there Karen
thank you so much for joining us to
answer these questions
thank you so much Zoe
and even though we couldn't get to all
your questions thank you to everyone who
submitted one for those of you wondering
about what new generative AI technology
means for the future of work
particularly creative Fields like art
we're going to get into that next Monday
until then you can catch regular
episodes of tech news briefing in this
feed and if you want even more Tech news
check out our website wsj.com
Today's show was produced by Julie Chang
we had production support from Madison
Conte our supervising producer is
Melanie Roy and our executive producer
is Chris sinsley this episode was mixed
by Michael Laval and I'm your host Zoe
Thomas Thanks so much for listening
[Music]